but you just can't see past the fact
that they affiliate with that religion
what do you know about their religion
arot no I don't care what anybody says I
Allah is my I am excited to watch this
this
is Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a s for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you can
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends I'll be reacting inah to
Muhammad hijabs first ever Drama Series
in why is this important brothers and
sisters the far right is exponentially
growing in Netherlands Austria nearly
France we know what's going on in Israel
Subhan Allah with the far right and what
they're doing he even here in the UK
with Nigel faraj now what does this mean
as you guys know I have tackled the far
right many times in person face to face
because they have to be confronted in
person because they are people of liars
they're just lying individuals so this
movie is very important because it comes
from different angles now I don't know
much about the movie but
I want to watch it first time with you
guys in it's coming out in the 22nd of
July it's so important for us to use new
ways as long as it's permissible and we
have our evidences and fatwa it is
absolutely Paramount for us to use the
media to promote Islam and make Allah's
cam the highest so I want to watch this
in brother sisters and see my reactions
I am excited it's the same with the
marriage documentary with my personal
thing brother sisters the second part
obviously I couldn't bring it out
because of the whole issue of Gaza
situation but it's so important for us
to take these initiatives up like take
it up a notch with our production and
the way we do things by communicating
the same message in unique ways in so
alhamdulillah and also like J Fran and
somebody that I spoke was
confrontational face to face but again
when you give people time and they
realize you can see that she had an
interview with d Hussein and subh opened
up and you can see she is more open to
understanding and having a dialogue this
is why it's so important for us to use
constructive um creative ways of getting
the da across to the non-muslims and
this is a brilliant initiative let's
watch for ourself God I hope they move
you somewhere a bit nicer so in that bad
GE we got some lovely
neighbors well except except what got
this Neighbor Next Door he's always
making noise and chanting his prayer in
there you ain't got one of them living
next door to you have
you one of
them you know babe
Muslims what's wrong with
Muslims a lot of my make the
Muslims it ain't the people themselves
I'm sure if it weren't for that cult
religion there'll be decent hardworking
people you just can't see past the fact
that they affiliate with that religion
what do you know about their religion AR
no I don't care what anybody says I'll
be honest I'll be honest Allah is my
witness W I am excited to watch this
this is an an angle where he's come from
Subhan Allah like to see look in my
documentary I have Muslims it's about
Muslims it's about my story here it's
like that I think that individual is
Tommy Robinson blood sounds like him
okay so it's it's so profound I'll be
honest with you I am so excited to watch
this I don't know if you guys are but I
cannot wait to see this because it seems
like it's going to be epic to have a
Muslim narrative in there with this it's
brilliant may Allah accepted for those
who put the effort in inah aldah muhamed
has consulted the scholars and got the
ruling alhamdulillah with obviously the
things you know scenes you might say oh
the woman in the hijab Etc we've
discussed in another video but guys I am
excited to watch this inshah I'll be
honest with you so keep tuned inah and
make sure that if you watch it and you
benefit from it which I have no doubt
you would please share it far on one
it's very important for us to work
together and share this especially with
your non-muslim friends it is so key for
us to use hikma in the da dawa is not
just done in one specific way
alhamdulillah yeah so brother and sister
inshallah I hope you guys are as excited
as I am I'll be honest with you I am
inshallah keep an eye on that 22nd of
July Muhammad Channel part one is going
to be out to me me and my family cannot
wait to watch it in